منذ 7 أكتوبر الحوثيون من
اليمن أطلقوا صواريخ كروز
تجاه إسرائيل هاجموا أه بل
وخطفوا سفينة تجارية في
البحر الأحمر وأرسلوا طائرات بدون طيار باتجاه السفن الأمريكية
كم أنت قلق من هذه
الهجمات الحوثية أه وما هي الرسائل التي
توصلها إلى  نظرة مباشرة للحوثيين نحن
واضحون أن التصعيد ليس في
مصلحة أحد وهذه هي الرسالة التي
نرسلها أه بكل وضوح نأمل أن
نتمكن من التركيز على إنهاء الوضع في
الرزة والصراع مخاطر
استمرار هذا الصراع وهذا الصراع
يتصاعد ويتصاعد  مهم
وحقيقي نحن ملتزمون بإنهاء
الحرب في اليمن وملتزمون بوقف
إطلاق النار الدائم أه الذي يفتح الباب
أمام عملية سياسية وسنواصل
العمل لتحقيق هذه الغاية
ونحن منخرطون بشكل كامل في ذلك
ولا أعتقد أننا سنرى
خطرًا كبيرًا على ذلك الآن السيد
وزير الخارجية، شكرًا جزيلاً لك،
شكرًا جزيلاً لك